the holding company
hello and welcome to all of
you, thank you for meeting us in the
press room of the european commission
for the daily meeting with the
press what we call our noon
briefing
today we have December 5, 2019 and
I  have some information to share
with you to start first the
european union to adopt new
measures of the two amounting to almost
300 million euros intended to
support refugees and host communities
from jordan and lebanon on  package was
adopted as part
of the european union's regional trust fund
in response to the syrian crisis
this fund provides vital assistance to
refugees fleeing war and to the country
hosting these syrian refugees
the european union has also decided to
extend  one-year mandate of the
trust fund which will allow its
projects to last until the end as early as 2023
you will find more
information in the daily news that and as
well as  in the press releases
that we have just published next to
where you from our way of life
i offer my butt there will be a
single gold in greece houston from a program
of life and death pact migration
of nalco ministers  company my drug mart
is now in greece
these visits are representative it is
then good news for
small and medium enterprises
we have announced today
it is the selection of 75 promising start-ups
and small and medium
enterprises  in the largest round
of funding since
the start of the pilot phase of the
European Innovation Council, amounting
to more than 278 million euros,
this funding will help accelerate
growth and help start-up
companies  innovative projects on the
market start-ups them and small and
medium-sized enterprises comes from 15 is a
member as well as from the five associated countries
again you will find
further information  ions on this subject in the
daily news as
well as with the telus team there is
a mode
good news hindisheim bing bing bang bang
and this new project investment and you
drop steel company hall guetta the
innovative visitors and
negationist romdhane morgue the slovak roms
ya  Paris missions